listen if you're going to clean goblins
out of your house
you don't want your ex-wife in there too
unless they can affect her too
oh my god hello everyone
hola mis amigos you're listening to oh
my god hi
i'm
paul
oh my god hi
[Music]
[Applause]
come on [ __ ] petra sally let's go
ryan doesn't buy
that look you know you're going to give
away your age when you're old
but there was a show called petro sally
and who was the star of that show
um he was in a lot of stuff
and he looks like brian he goes because
grant can you see this he looks just
like me
and i just popped in my head petra all
right petrol if everybody goes missing
let brian no [ __ ] picture he'll get
to the bottom from here
from here to oxnard a point why neemi
and anywhere
uh fine suits are sold i look like a
cracked out
petrocelli all right your guest today
actor writer comedian but wait a minute
this is something different
yes all right we don't have a guest
first puto like
get with a uh that's how you're gonna do
intros all the time
i figured i figured i'd start with him
but i'll start with something else
uh today what we're gonna do what we're
going to do today
is we're going to have our guests first
and then we'll bear to get that [ __ ]
speech
uh straightened out you're slurring you
haven't had a drop of alcohol
this is going to be the easiest show
okay come on come on come on let's go
today we have momo rodriguez with us
today
and as you all know he's an actor
comedian producer but he's also very
well connected
with him you all know [ __ ] nobody
knows
well on the on the on the whole let's
say on the whole right i think mama
would be
probably not the first one but by the
third one to say
you know i take three this guy this guy
i've known he was around us for a long
time he worked with other communities
we're not going to say
because that's not what it's about but
in my association with this young man
here
over the last five years i have not met
a smarter
more dependable a
not a as a writer as a technician
as somebody to be your friend to to give
you advice than
momo rodriguez thank you so much this
guy means a lot to me so thank you
and also i've lived in my house in in
los angeles
since september of 2014
and you know living alone and
uh finding that house even looking at
the house you know all these people
wanted to buy it and for some reason you
know the realtor
when i went downstairs after looking at
it says do you i'm trying i'm trying to
get a lot of the details out but in
a short time because what we're going to
talk about is is really
eerie and important and strange and
fascinating and
scary all at once it was almost like
going to shop for a while so so um
the guy said you want it i called the
guys and i didn't give me the full offer
and i got it so when i went in there
i i had you know been divorced for maybe
four years i'd lived
in places that i wasn't gonna own
nothing i really liked
growing up i always wanted to live in
los feliz from the time i went to the
observatory
in 1973 when i was in fifth grade and uh
i said you know i love this area going
to dodger stadium you pass a sign that
says feel it's going and
coming and going and all of a sudden i
got in my head and i'm used to taking
those feelings from
the five to hollywood so that area
became very dear to my heart i know
front end venezuela lives
in that area i know you know that people
lived in there that were celebrities and
stuff
and you know i get this house and uh
maybe i'm in there for it's a pretty big
house for a person that's
alone and i i would probably gonna say
that in the
in the first few months
i heard i heard somebody say
ma when i was i'm a light sleeper
and it's all kind of wood you know avoid
the carries in there
and i heard ma and i'm like
upstairs and i'm going man i heard
somebody say
ma pay attention i would hear it again
and i would hear things moving around
and i'm like no this can't be like
this this can't be so early on
you know i'm not believing it and i hear
ma again
and i'm like somebody lives here
somebody's in here
and i go down one time
i go down with a gun i get a gun and i
go down of course like a stupid ass i
have it pointed down
so if i trip over my [ __ ] feet i'm
gonna blow up
you know a hole right through the top of
my foot
and three more you can climb you can put
me up hey from the observatory come by
and get me easter
uh and so i'm immediately cause i'm so
i'm so afraid i don't know you're
supposed to have the gun up you know
and i'm and then since then
you know i was doing some work to it and
i think one of the one of the things
that happened that was
you know born in general hospitals
probably less than five miles from there
maybe three miles from there
and i was born when i was born my
grandmother you know my mom's the nurse
said we're going to call him and
my mom wanted to call him after the guy
they thought was my father my grandma
was like that's not going to happen what
day is it go to the calendar what day is
it
it's april 23rd saint george's day all
right his name is george
all right george edward for my nino
lopez
i was born on the day of saint george i
have some work done at the house
all the fireplaces are blacked out and
things are just sloppy you tell the
contractor hey
can you sand blast all this stuff away
it's like seven layers of of
of paint on the wall and then he calls
me up and
and he goes i'm leaning for the day when
you get home
i know you want to remove the fireplace
take a look inside because there's a
conquistador
tile inside the fireplace and i get home
and i look in there
and it's not a conquistador it's a tile
from the 1920s of st
george slaying the dragon wow man
so i'm like how how is that even
possible man how is that possible
and then when momo starts to come over
i start to mention to him that
there's you know i hear things in the
house and what what have you seen or
felt
since you've been over when you told me
you were hearing noises i was afraid
oh like kind of just felt eerie going to
your downstairs sunroom
something was just i didn't like being
alone there and if you're alone at
georgia's house you kind of feel like
that little bit of a sinking
presence or something heavy comes over
you in that little area so i never
wanted to go against you it wasn't your
reflection by yourself
like you're like oh that's me and i
didn't want to be downstairs and then
it was one day when we were doing this
um this uh
commercial for uh a food app and you
were in upstairs and i was downstairs
setting up
the lady who was doing sound that day
said hey can the lady that's walking
back and forth
not walk back and forth so we can set
this shot up and i'm like there's no
lady here
and she goes well i hear somebody
talking in the kitchen
in with the microphones so she picked it
up and she's like there's nobody here
she freaked out
and she goes there's just something here
and i just didn't say anything i don't
alarm anybody so that was one thing but
the part that really got me was that one
day when i was downstairs
and i saw somebody going back and forth
through the he has these like bar like
these bar
doors that go from his living room into
his sunroom
and they were just moving back and forth
and and i even said to george and i
never even you know how do you tell
somebody that you don't think that's a
gordito
of you like when you get momentum
sometimes when people are heavy and they
fall like the air goes by after they
fall
right well no i mean like when you're
following a semi truck
and then like 10 feet later they're like
goddamn what the [ __ ] yeah it was [ __ ]
in here
right well you do you do feel stupid
like that because you know you're heavy
and the
floor does make noise yeah and this
floor does make a lot of noise
uh you know when you walk in any kind of
you know noise you hear so you're
thinking is it the house settling is it
something
but then you know one night george gives
me a call
and he shares these videos with me and
i'm like you know
i think there's somebody in my house and
i'm like oh it's probably the something
settling probably the wind
and he shared with me this video of
people just banging downstairs like just
boom boom boom
doors opening up and you know it wasn't
really that you can't really tell what
it was
like you can't say oh that was the door
slamming there was no way to
actually describe the sound so that that
kind of freaked all of us out and ever
since that day
we've been hearing noises about i'm
right i took a voice box a spirit box
um i was a paranormal investigator for
about 10 years that's right there's a
good background here
so i do you know i did haunted houses
with a bunch of mediums and stuff stuff
like that
so i took a spirit box to george's house
and we were sitting in his sunroom
and we just left it on and as we left it
on it was having a conversation with
george
in real time it was saying george's name
it was saying
his daughter's name me was saying all
these things that nobody would have
known
you know and how a spirit box works is
that it picks up a higher frequency of
voices that are being told
they say those are spirit voices trying
to communicate i don't recommend anybody
do that because once you open up that
channel
it's i think about a year you're in a
house you live you've been dead for a
hundred years
you're stuck there and someone starts
talking to you don't do it
if you if anybody's out there and you
think that you
hear things in your house or presence
listen i'm i'm not pretending that i've
heard things
i've heard things i'll put stuff up when
you guys watch this
there's banging there's words
there's the the thing you know the thing
that
freaked me out i went you know i did
cedric's show then i went to you know
ann's house and mine was there
and i was telling him about the house
and ann's you know [ __ ] hand you know
uh i don't think i could say that by the
court but nobody
knows so anne's like i know this lady
that can
clean your house and then you know we
had a house and i'm like i i
i look at that talking about your house
talk about my house
i'm gonna [ __ ] about a house in [ __ ]
monterey give a [ __ ] about that
it freaked me out so much that i told
mayan like i'm i'm like afraid to go
home and then she's like you want me to
go with you and i'm like
what's that gonna do you're gonna hear a
[ __ ] noise you're gonna start crying
i'm gonna get mad at you and now we're
both gonna be [ __ ]
so i'm like i'd rather go through it
alone because it's
it's it's alive
and it's religious there's something
there's and then this weekend
i'm i'm i'm
i showing somebody and i zeroed in
and there's a picture it's not a mirror
there's a picture in the hallway
that's giving off a reversed inflection
and there's a
[ __ ] image of a person three people
in the reflection from the light in the
hallway
yeah and i zero in on it and it's faces
and it's a mustache and it's a person
wearing white
and yeah it's it it
it's too much for me now i did some
research on your house
a few days ago all right and i'm i'm i
haven't been
you know this this is the day i haven't
been there i haven't been there at night
yet tonight's the first this is your
first night back oh wow now your house
was built in 1920s
and during the 1920s i mean that house
has had from what i've
read about eight different owners now
the longest owner was there for like
about 40 years
and there's a lot of of her names
well there's no name that's the thing i
don't know
that girl horvath i told my uncle one
time a name
like i think it was maybe and he kept
saying it for like [ __ ] three months
and i'm like dude what are you doing
i'm trying like a month later i'm still
working on that horror bag
i'm like [ __ ] obsessed [ __ ]
obsessive compulsive
that's back there when you were just
being a [ __ ] pain in the ass
sitting in a chair rocking back and
forth horror
goddamn a lot of people have a house
have a property that's haunted it's the
house right
but in george's case he's he has a lot
of experiences that follow him away from
his house
so i think on this one i think whatever
is going on in his house
is something that is attached to him and
it's not the actual property and the
reason i say is because
george um maybe before you were on tour
uh you know you were you were gone every
weekend listen man and
and when you go on tour like there's
you know every first of all this this
all this stuff isn't like new to me
i won't say like i'm an intuitive but
but i've had pretty good intuition for
myself and growing up in the house
and you might you know you can't be a
mexican without you know
thinking you know that yorona or she
lives down the street or a lady with
three kids
you know and then you [ __ ] around and
you scare your friends like we're
walking we're walking from little league
and there's a lady that we know
is in the yorona and she's watering the
grass at 6 30 it's starting to get dark
and we're like
we [ __ ] take off running you're like
you [ __ ] ass me
so anybody be kendo yorona so
it's not like i feel things for the
first time since i moved in the house i
felt it my whole life and then
when we start to tour and we go to those
old theaters one of the first things i
ask them is this place haunted
and of course they all are like that
time that guy said when we were in
reading pennsylvania
did that guy leave and he goes oh this
guy just left because this guy was gone
on vacation and a woman who was an usher
passed away
and they had the funeral the guy was
away so he came back
and after a half hour he said oh i was
talking to
the woman for like 20 minutes and she
was telling me about what she's been up
to and the guy's like what are you
talking about yeah i saw her
in the hallway up there where she in her
aisle and the guy
said dude she she passed man
and he's like there's no way she passed
i was just i was just talking to her and
that has happened
more often than not and i asked for it
which i think
now i know is stupid uh to do that
to ask anybody to come and visit you or
to ask if this place is haunted i'm not
doing that anymore
so but quite often on the road though
you've you've heard people
on stage you've heard people walk by you
and you probably did you because you're
so [ __ ]
drunk after two years the [ __ ] ghosts
were gangbanging
we heard one together with you guys i
heard with you guys we were in
sacramento and uh we were in the green
room the three of us
and george was given this this gift by
one of the clubs
the little speaker that you have yeah oh
yeah and with the speaker was on top of
the refrigerator and the speaker
flew off the refrigerator just flew off
and landed up right now it landed
perfect
on the floor it was like a cartoons like
and everybody just stopped and went what
and
i asked is something wrong with this
club they're like oh yeah the green room
is is
what about downstairs it sounds like
what dishes are being washed
oh the glasses remember we saw we heard
them you and i heard them crazy yeah we
were both going do you hear what i hear
yeah yeah
so it's all over the place you know and
and
which is fine you don't you don't i
don't want it in my house
i don't wanna i don't you know in the
beginning it was intriguing
and this video from october that i've
i've looked at
there's you know orbs flying around yeah
that time we did that thing for la
originals and the orb would go by me
oh yeah that was a small orb go you know
really fast
and now in my bedroom when i would hear
a noise i started to video
and then you see orb was going around in
circles
and up and across and then the one that
freaked me out that i showed
that i'm going to put on the podcast
everybody can see it is i zeroed in and
it looked like the lamp
was twisting then it looked like there
was a kind of a mist
and the light was changing yeah and then
the reflection
i didn't see i can't see the i don't
want to look at the reflection
of the video when it's on video but then
i took a picture of it and when i
zeroed in on it this will all be there
for everybody to see
that there's an image in the reflection
of i i think it's three people and one
and one is more prominent than
than the others yeah he sent it to me in
the middle of the night
and uh and i like to watch these videos
i like to really watch him and you know
kind of like see what it is
and in that video one thing that i
noticed and i've seen so many paranormal
videos
his orbs are different colors now if it
was a bug
it would be usually white and the reason
bugs light up
orbs in there he had green ones like a
little blue
yeah baby
and when you see them fly by they turn
the bat
a little circle they won't make any
noise they won't make any kind of color
because the
the infrared's capturing them so what
freaked me out was the fact that we're
seeing
these little you know things coming out
without any infrared special lighting
so what he was catching was happening
right in front of him and he was
experiencing it as it happened i mean
he just didn't take out his camera just
to film nothing
people catch orbs and never didn't
expect it he was actually pointing at
something he felt
and when he pointed the camera something
was coming out like who has a green mist
coming out of their house and it wasn't
even visible through the eye but he felt
something and he started recording
here comes the green mix i mean it's
great paranormal activity and then the
one with the
the one where it just sounds like
something is just being thrown lifted
and dropped at the same time
for you know i try not to make the
videos too long because it doesn't go
away
and that one time when it was rattling
out like what the
[ __ ] is this and i went to sleep
because once i went around again with a
gun this time the right way
and i turned it i opened the attic which
was scary imagine going to the [ __ ]
attic by myself and then the attic has a
light
and i open the [ __ ] doors and there's
nothing in there and i'm like
and the [ __ ] sound is still coming
out of there i leave the light on i go
back to my room and the sound is still
coming out of there
and then i i the next day i asked that
the this exterminator come to see if
there's any droppings of any animals in
there there would be
like something in there nothing and
it's just it's it
it's too much man not the [ __ ]
winchester mystery household
yeah that's like classic it's too much i
can't take i can't take it anymore
and the reflections in that in that in
that
it's not a mirror it's a reflection in a
painting in the wall
is is the almost the last straw
so i'm not gonna you know ann's like
well i'm gonna get that lady to clean
your house
and i don't listen if you're gonna clean
goblins out of your house
you don't want your ex-wife in there too
unless it can affect her too my god
oh my god but what i want you to be
there to have the smoke not affect you
so uh she's not invited if i end up
using that person but there's a lot of
people that'll do it yeah yeah
but do i want do i want to have
paranormal investigators go in there and
set up the cameras in the middle of the
night no
i don't you don't want that no i don't
recommend it
man dude if there's a devil in that
house matter some evil spirit
some mean spirit miguel when he went to
go get incense felt something in there
yeah
and ran out of the house yeah he ran the
lady that watches the dogs hear stuff
and she tries not to make a big deal out
of it i didn't i mean told her anything
about this which i probably should
there's a horrible
yeah but you but you learned you have
some really creepy stories that you
shared with
we did like over 30 haunted houses and
everybody always thinks
and i'm going to say you know in general
they all think it's a demon
number one they think they're being
possessed by an evil spirit that's just
that's the biggest thing
and i'm i want to tell people right now
like i have a podcast called parago
activity pockets we talk about
all these things and people call in and
everybody says there's a devil in my
house look it's not a demon
it's not a devil because if it was you
wouldn't be talking about it right now
right it would really take you over what
you have in your house is not evil
it's just very uncomfortable and it's
pretty creepy i mean
any noise even a mouse making a noise is
creepy at night time
so what it is it's you know it's unknown
and that's what creeps everybody out
what it possibly might be is some kind
of attachment to either your house or to
you
you know you had a lot of cleansing done
uh maybe four years ago when you did
that one
shows uh very uh very superstitious oh
yeah yeah yeah once you do that
cleansing
you want to come to my house no but you
did a lot of treasure you did a lot of
cleansing all about yourself
oh [ __ ] about that so in new orleans
that [ __ ] don't carry the [ __ ]
gonna end up like from new orleans in
the in the house where'd you come from
i'm from new orleans
how about you mexico i think you're the
other [ __ ] ghost on the path horrible
will unfortunately what would you guess
the puzzle horror if i was on tv i
probably said horrible
just want to say jordan if you're out
here on tv again don't say my name they
say horror back
so i can keep it on my phone
so so but he know but he knows and you
know there's stuff that you played for
me
over there at the check this out i don't
everybody listen to this one this is
this one from the from the beach or the
park this one we went to the
we went to a park in pico rivera or the
people have been saying this is where
they people
and i heard voices in my house too but
but not like this
now this this video is from this park
and when we went to the park we were
told that
there's a lot of noises there people
have died there overdoses at night time
people party
so we want a [ __ ] good place to go
you ever seen a chalk outline of
somebody dead yeah
that's i'm old school i remember seeing
different color chalk to blue for a boy
at pink for
if her name was a gender reveal
we went to this park and when we were
doing the investigation
we felt something going on with the
psychic he said there was somebody
chasing him
he said we should get out of here and
i'm like well let's start recording and
he did an evp session
evp session is electric voice phenomenon
it's when you record your session you're
talking to these ghosts
and then you play it back on a higher
frequency sometimes you hear their their
voices in the higher frequency
in the playback and this is what we
caught is a real short
can you one the swings do something
here yeah i jump
so that could have been either a suicide
or something you know going on but
that's been the clearest evp that i've
caught i mean we've caught in some like
growling some weird noises but this was
actually
an actual person this one was the one
that made me stop doing the paranormal
investigating
because we were i was followed by some
for like about a month
yeah i was going to ask you did you did
something stick to you oh yeah they
stick to you because think about it no
one's just talking to you
and then somebody's now listening to you
they're gonna stick to you right
and if you were you remind them of
somebody they will stick to you till
like
forever forever if you're in a house and
you think you
feel something or like even in at the
other house that i have
now i sent you guys that tape the orb
yeah and during the day i took a picture
and there's a there's like a white
uh more of a of a different light by the
doorway that's not normal if you take a
picture
that's not going to come out so now it's
over there
and then i videoed because last night in
that doorway i fell to the doorway
orb goes by and i just you know i'm
watching tv and i look i'm like there's
some there's somebody there's something
in the courtyard
but i didn't go in the courtyard and i
even said
i'm not coming outside so
whoever's out i'm not coming i'm not
coming outside yeah
like i'll stay inside you stay outside
i'm like i was married again you stay
out the [ __ ] out there
[ __ ] that's all so so now it's
it's a trip and i you know i i slept
with almost most of the lights on
over there and i went to bed at like 9
30 and i got up at five and i got the
[ __ ] out of there
and now i gotta wait for it to get dark
over there so i can
start to hear the you know the show
starts out about atlanta
oh my gosh and there is a way to make
you go away and and
when people's you know what the usual
thing is you burn some palo santo you
burn some sage you smudge the house
but i mean that's that's pretty much
what that lady would come and do what
about what about when you came over and
you said there's a little girl
standing right next to you there's
somebody attached to george now i'm not
saying i'm psyched but sometimes i get
these weird feelings and if you
watch some of my stuff you'll see that
i'm doing this stuff george has this
little girl attached to him
and i don't know if it was a sister that
little girl from woody island i found
that oh
[Laughter]
so he feels like he has a female
president walking around his house
and even the i think it's a lady because
every time he he said he heard a woman's
voice say mom
you know you know it's a female voice
around his house
somebody a sister that he hadn't even
know he had you know
a lot of times too when our parents have
miscarriages
those people are attached to us too
we've had many cases with our medium
says that you had a did your mom lose a
daughter
and you know that daughter is attached
to the person that's born next
i mean that's how that's how crazy and
then we have this a mutual friend of
ours aj pereira
amazing media medium to like the stars
and some of the stuff he's done it's
hard to even explain it to be
you know false yeah and he's the guy
that we went to with all these
investigations he was the guy that that
was his voice right now you're heard in
the evp oh that was him
you know the the one time i was over
there i was watching a documentary a
little girl that that painted and you
know she was on 60 minutes and then they
questioned whether she really had the
talent as the painter or whether that
was painting
and you know i draw and i've been trying
to paint forever but never really do it
but up there with some canvases and some
paints oh yeah so i said oh i'm gonna
get a canvas and
a paint i couldn't find any brushes so i
used my finger to just kind of paint a
face you know
and then we talked to aj
yeah and then later that day aj said
um like are you are you drawing are you
painting and i said yeah i painted today
he got it from from me from that well
george is so great at picking up energy
from i mean that's you know being a
performer he just he gives it to
everybody every night
and i think he did that to me one time
when we did the your grandfather thing
too
oh yeah you know he i showed to his
house and
he was just talking about his
grandfather with somebody and
i was sitting there where i was having a
beer just looking at george and i go
and i just the word encanto and it just
came to me
and then george looks at me tells me
that's what my grandpa used to call me
wow he goes [ __ ] normal that's right
man
oh man grandpa used to call me enganto
and i took it as an insult and i'm
almost like no man that's like what is
it like enchantment
you're my you're my enchantment you're
my everything me and kanto it's a
mariachi song
that i've heard it from you it doesn't
mean you hate it when you call me them
yeah so we're in my room and he says all
of a sudden
like what did you say i said you know
hey i said george is gonna sound weird
man but i'm thinking about mariachis
what does encanto mean to you and then i
i said
who why did you say that and i'm like
you said he said well you said i'm like
i don't know i'm like who told you to
say that
what do you who told you he goes nothing
that came to me yeah
my grandfather called me oh that's a
hair raising oh man it was weird for me
because i'm like
he came out of you i think my uncle's
coming right through right now horrified
still what are you doing one thing i'm
doing watching the girls go by thinking
to myself horrible
now
so he could possibly do that well what
happened with me is i kept on seeing
this guy that's the worst thing
he was saying another word [ __ ] no i
like there's not too much to let you
change it
you just told him not to leave man you
have at nighttime
when you're someone that's a sensitive
you have something called sleep
paralysis where
you wake up but you can't move your body
but everything else you can you can see
that happens for a few seconds and
usually during that time you see either
things coming at you
voices or people in the room and then
once you snap
out of it you go back to normal that's
having an outer body experience there's
a movie about it called insidious that's
what it's pretty much based on
but a lot of people who have the sleep
paralysis usually they're being followed
by somebody or have some kind of
intuition or their intuitives that can
actually leave their body
and when you're able to do that you're
receptive to all the energies around you
george is one of them george has a lot
of energy so whenever something
paranormal comes around
it attracts to him you know and i mean
i've had people
i've had people feel like they've sat at
the end of my bed
i think the first time i happened in
florida coconut grove at the
coconut grove thing there um
and i turned all the lights on and i'm
like what the [ __ ] man who was in here
happened a few times
and i told aj that it happened two
weekends ago at the house i was trying
to lay down
like 4 30 and i'm laying there and
it happened this weekend too so i have
the remote on my chest
and the remote moves and i'm like
did the remote just move on its own i'm
like oh
[ __ ] i [ __ ] went like that
you know you watch tv like this yeah and
then you know you fall asleep and you
just
oh man you know who it is and didn't you
tell you who it was no
it's you aj will tell you that calm
today i'll tell you it's you're the one
doing that you're the one that to flee
your bed
you're the one that's leaving and coming
back so when you come back until you
might hear a noise
and wakes you up or you might or or you
might see darkness coming towards you
some people see that or they hear a loud
noise or they hear themselves like say
something can anybody see me out there
well no it's you're like a different
person
i'm out there like that
[Laughter]
there's a way to stop doing that all you
got to do is before you go to bed you
say to yourself i don't want to leave
anywhere i just want to stay home
and it sounds weird sounds dumb i think
that's a stupid thing he's probably
telling me
which one to tell george like yeah they
put a camera in there i don't
want to stay home tonight and all the
mediums are laughing
yeah everybody's laughing about it it
worries me
i i mean i've had to see perhaps a lot
and i said myself hey i don't want to go
nowhere tonight
let me sleep because it's your it's your
subconscious doing that stuff now is it
is it paranormal is it just our
our mind and is it is it science who
knows but if you do
it's in the end of the day you're
actually having the experience so it
just has to do with you
so you can control it now if somebody
pulls you out of the bed
it's a [ __ ] deal it's a demon it's a
demon but if it's just you know use
something dark something weird
movements i mean it's it's mostly it's
it's our own subconscious and it's our
own
uh uh soul or whatever you want to call
it in a different plane
you know and then you're a real soulful
guy i mean you know you have a lot of
soulful stuff in your house
you have crystals when i was little i
wanted to be lou rob
who didn't so i have a lot of crystals
in my house yes
and chris yes it's a good and
bad thing because crystals are also
amplifiers
so let's say you do have energy there
you're just amplifying the energy
yeah you know it's you you have strong
ghost wi-fi at your house what you're
doing
and then you have a lot of amazing
collectibles at your house that are like
mean something spiritual to you right it
might not mean to anybody but to you
their prices because they mean something
when you have those kind of price
positions at your house you're just
bringing more energy into that house you
know there's a lot of things in
that that people have owned
famous people and people who were
personal to me and people who were
famous that i knew personally
and um
you know if you get a better
understanding of it and you know that
it's
not evil yeah i would rather
keep it the way it is than to remove
those things
and have the house be more antiseptic
to where you know it's clear and that
nothing's ever going to be there again
yeah i would rather keep it almost the
way it is
those images in the in that picture i
don't like
of course and when you zero when i zoom
in on they're
not good looking faces and those are the
things that
that scare me because that's
you know like was it 10 feet from me
yeah it's right there it's your bed
and that's we'll put those things up
there those images are
they're not in whatever that paint that
that
print is does not have those images
but the person that did that or drew
that
is not alive anymore and it could be
he touched the paper yeah so if they
are doing things i just remembered right
now that yeah that's somebody who was
very famous
internationally and if
it was in his a warehouse
and what and everything he had was in
his warehouse so of course now it makes
sense that that if there was something
that yeah
that thing sat in his surrounded by his
possessions
i mean after he left the earth there's a
movie about that i mean there's a movie
the
the movie annabelle the movie hannah
bill was based on an actual i've been to
that i've seen the
real anabolic i've been to the house in
connecticut the
the museum of the occult where they have
everything now the the
the anabolic is in the room full of
every single artifact and relic
that the family used and took from all
these haunted houses
whenever you have something like that
that's why never go to
antiquing because you're just taking
people's energy and putting them into
your house
i mean there's something perfect
something is called an impression in
concert houses
let's say somebody moves into a house
they have a horrible divorce
they argue like crazy and they leave the
house the next couple that moves in that
follows the same criteria as that family
will inherit that same energy get a
divorce and leave
there's a movie about that called the
amityville horror same thing happened
the family matched exactly the family
who left and and they
fit that impression when we bought the
house in
in to luca lake you know the the woman
that sold it
said everybody that's lived in this
house has gotten divorced
and i remember ann said well that's not
going to happen to us and you know i
knew i was already still so i was like
yeah
yeah like the worst cheerleader in the
world
that's not going to happen to us out
george no
why would it choke in the air
who would say that to sell a house
that's crazy hey everybody in this house
is getting a divorce
here are the keys half fat [ __ ]
realtor
[ __ ] hey go buy a house with
somebody who who's underweight
they've been living on the street for 10
years
and their pictures like you see them on
the on the on the uh bus stops or in the
air or wherever you know
this house sold by sue swan go look at
who's supposed to
sue ducks
oh god huh it's real stuff a little bit
of masa behind her legs with their
bedroom
making bread we're breaking bread at
home tonight spread bread
yeah all right so let's so let's see all
right so that's we covered that
so in your in both of your opinions
though there's nothing
demonic or evil in the house that you're
both don't ask my opinion here
i've been look i've been in georgia a
lot of times i've been there i mean late
night
no i don't think anything negative it's
creepy if you hear a noise in the middle
of the night in any house yeah
all right you know and and another thing
george has a lot of trees outside i mean
there could be
so many things the houses from the 20s
it could be other noises mixed with
other ghostly noises the bouncing of
that the sound of this that's not
the the drop the video you showed us or
you're actually
talking during the video and saying
listen to this you hear this
and you hear the noises happening yeah
that's he would have to have somebody
down there doing stuff like a whole
production
from where the noise was coming out of
there that is real the voice box people
ghost talking
that was real is it evil no is it
personal yes
everything in his house is connected to
george do you think i should take that
that print down that's in the hallway no
because then you're giving in it's like
it's like you're you're feeding
it with more energy some dog piss on the
corners or anything like that no i know
i think remember that dude that tried to
put deer piss on himself
and the deer came out and [ __ ] his ass
up like hey [ __ ] thought he was
going to get some [ __ ]
some beer that guy's like a hunter he
got a deer here and he puts it on him
oh the deer cut out with a big old
[ __ ] rod he's like hey [ __ ]
you're not a deer
and he was up on his hind feet like
cutting
you know the guy put a deer piss to
attract
a deer yeah of course but he attracted a
dude like that's almost like
you know here we go can't save him
you know like like you smell perfume you
think it's a it's a woman
just that all right and then for
everyone who go around buying stage at
the store not still trying to be all
holistic
this is the way you do sage this is the
way you do a sage cleanse you buy a
piece of white sage
you cut it make it small enough you burn
it you go around every corner of your
house open your windows open your doors
you blow into us sometimes people use a
feather and use the feather to wave it
around
get that smoke on every single corner
when you're done use that sage that has
that's still burning and bury it in the
backyard do not save it
do not hang it somewhere like a
decoration you have to bury it you have
to give it back to the earth
it's a cleanse get it out of there
people save it they decorate it with it
same thing with palo santo now sage is
not to take away ghosts
sage is kind of to amplify good positive
energy and take away negative energy
if you want to take away ghosts you use
lavender there's other different ways to
do it use palo santo
a little stick you can buy do the same
thing you go around every corner
and palo santo is more for cleansing
objects so what i would do
for your house because you know your
house is too big to go to every freaking
corner
and it's just smell like sage and stink
everything up it's not worth it get palo
santo and go to the areas that you feel
uncomfortable in
and just do some palo santo ceremony say
a prayer that means something to you
whatever religion you want to believe
whatever prayer you want to say that
means
that's true to you because it's it's
following you it's chasing you
right and then you're done and that's it
and don't pay more attention to it
don't use voice boxes don't play do not
ever play with the ouija board
never ever
don't listen people that are out there
or the cards don't do the cards
don't do the cards oh don't do cards and
don't and don't [ __ ] with the ouija
board
because you're gonna get a demon that or
somebody
bad to come through there and you're not
going to know how to make them go home
a lot of bad people that have had you
like yeah that come and visit and
they're right there
like hey first week they're good also
you can't find your [ __ ] watch or you
know that's how it is
you know they take off early and you
know you can't find your shoes
you know that kind of stuff and look
we've all we've all lost loved ones and
we would want
so bad to connect to our loved ones
people that have passed on
you want to say well can i reach my mom
can i reach my dad someone who's passed
on
when you're out there looking for
something something else will answer the
call right
you're not he'll pretend to be like i
see in the movie yeah it'll pretend to
be
what you want it to be but in reality
it'll be something demonic
and and then you know serious too yeah
yeah they will get they'll they'll stay
with you though though you know and you
know
being like being possessed is not like
in the movies where you're pit you know
you're spitting out green [ __ ] you know
your head turns
being possessed nowadays is being
negative every [ __ ] day
hating people and you know being rude
with people divorce
that's a possession that's a real
possession most demon possessions are
when people get mad at each other like
let's say someone you know is acting
like an
[ __ ] the whole week he's not himself
that's a possession
it's not you know them flying across the
room so i mean that's why people you
know should go get a cleanse and you
know
what about your house like that like
people act like that you get a couple
beers and then everybody's
like making love and playing music but
without those beers
yeah if you're playing the devil's
the demon's bullet train there you go
because you're stopping the temple
you're messing up next time you got a
little kid running around his jones
brian's got more little mexican kids
running around no safety but their
parents are in the room but
but no i've never seen a kid in his
videos with a t-shirt on
i don't think we don't do that around
the house every everybody's in there
carlson and he had a little kid with a
ladder in his back
i said why would a little kid have a
ladder on the back of his panties
that's a that's one for you guys to
figure out a little kid three years old
with a ladder
he was possessed by a painter
but hey i'm worried about the tarot card
reading i i used to read cards to make
my extra money
right anything that has like your nose i
never told too many lies
anything that has a demon or has the
devil or has the
death on a card you know you're playing
with death whenever you throw the cards
and there's a picture of death you're
you're you're doing props
come on man it's like here oh i mean
think about it says this card has a
if the card has a picture of a guy
that's gonna
that says that you're gonna die or death
yeah but that's pretty big
no the death card doesn't mean you're
gonna die so if there's a if there's a
parallel universe
and those people are gone yeah so they
see
us playing with the cards and it's
mocking death
which i think you're making fun of death
or reducing
or making more of life you owe death
something in return
that's why they have santa muerte people
that use santeria they use santa muerte
you know the statue of death they're
using death as a way to you know
for flavors but that means you got to
pay death back and you know they'll pay
him back by laying the candle for him
giving him a piece of bread but if you
miss that candle or mess that bread it
takes your life
because that's what you're doing to deal
with okay so what about led zeppelin so
i i love led zeppelin listen to the book
great but jimmy jimmy page was into
aleister crowley who studied black magic
yes
yes kenneth kenneth anger this lang
anger this guy that bit
babylon but he was a disciple and
studied with crowley
that jimmy page and this guy kenneth
anger were working on a film and jimmy
page was doing the music
and they had a falling out and kenneth
anger put a curse
of king midas which means you know you
re you know midas is the rich guy
that things will crumble around you on
jimmy page and his old lady because
he threw him out of the place where he
was staying he wouldn't let him get his
stuff
so he said i put a curse on you but then
jimmy page was dabbling in black magic
and then you know somebody lost a child
i don't want to say the name
and then john bonham died
and jimmy page had two people die in his
house
in less than a year and then
and then you if you want to believe you
know
i'm just saying as a as an observer and
just but but
it's down in their history as a band
that people thought you know because
jimmy page is messing with the occult
or black magic buying the i mean he
bought places that aleister crowley
lived and bought possessions yeah yeah
and bought books that he owned
they're all connected they're all i mean
look it's different than me having a
michael jackson
lithograph in my hallway that has faces
coming out
it's okay with a little ladder
it's all connected because if you see if
you do this experiment if you were to
boil
you know if you were to steam white rice
put it in one container
like like a tupperware do that to two
pieces two cups of rice right
it sound delicious
what kind of demons are at your house
with carrots
you get so you get one of the sage of
the eggs
eight by eight double double four by
four so you get one of those
so you get one of the tupperware's full
of the white rice and you use it you
grab it and you say
every single negative feeling you have
say negative things to that right say
every every bad wait a minute wait a
minute
so say it again because i was i was
[ __ ] around and i think this is going
to be something
it's a good experiment to do okay so you
boil you steam rice
you take one scoop of that white rice
when it's steamed put it in a little
tupperware cup that's sealed off
or you can put in a ziploc bag you hold
on to that piece of rice
and you just say the most negative
things that you have on your mind about
people about yourself
about anything do nothing but negativity
while you hold that rice and look at the
rice
then grab another piece of rice with
another tupperware hold on to that one
and say nothing but positive influential
things that rice
within one week the negative rice will
brown and rot
and the other one will still be fresh
google it it's on google people always
do this that just shows the power of
negativity
wow this is a story that this is a great
one so so we went to go play golf in the
desert years and years ago and then
this guy that like this woman she had
just lost
her may have been a boyfriend
um or husband that just passed so she's
a widow
and we we don't know what to expect she
shows up she's hot so it's me
another guy this guy willie and this
woman
and she's really thin and she's eating
like everybody's food you know she's
eating that she's talking about
her life and that she was in love with
this guy
and she's hot i mean willie's just like
zeroing in on her like just looking at
her and we're listening to her
and she's talking and she's eating and
she's like you know i want to kind of
restart my life but
i hear him and it's everybody that i
meet i hear his voice and it makes me
not want to get involved with anyone
because i can hear his voice
talking to me so she goes on for like 30
minutes about hearing her voice this he
was at the beach she met a guy
and then willie is sitting there and he
goes wait a minute i think i
i think i hear his voice right now
myself and we're all looking around
and we think he's serious and he goes
like this do
the friends
[Laughter]
oh man one of the most one of the
funniest things
that i've ever witnessed was that
because he was just a dry dude wasn't a
comedian wasn't entertainment owns
restaurants and
as she went on and on and just got more
hysterical he said wait a minute i think
i hear him right now
awesome all right momo thanks for coming
in bro awesome awesome to see you
and thanks for all that information momo
rodriguez we'll keep everybody posted on
what's going on we're going to post some
pictures video
and a link to momo's perigordo
activities
there's one of him eating ice cream with
no shirt on that has over 2 million
views
now that's paranormal and petro sally
will be right back
after bonanza
all right well momo's going to stick
around for the news so let's uh get
started with our first
one you guys will appreciate it this is
[ __ ] exciting when you you know
you read so awful well i know that's
that's part of the charm i was hoping
anyways you're handsome because if you
look at my hair man i don't see myself
you don't have a lot of [ __ ] going for
you daddy
or bad
you know people grow up in the
neighborhood and he would say you know i
went over to this guy's house in
sacramento this guy
uh that guy trey hold that guy was on
the radio oh yeah
and his dad was a huge fan of mine this
was i think before so he would say
george
i lived here but this was all just feels
like plum
fields and he goes that and i know all
the kids that grew up in this
neighborhood like the girl right there
uh getting into the car you see her and
she's like hey waves hi mr trump
yeah george she's when she was a little
girl she'd be riding her bike right here
in front of the house and now you look
at it
you're like are you all right yeah no
i'm just talking about there's a girl
that lives two houses down when she was
little she used to
you know run around the street with a
balloon and now i saw her yesterday
remember hands across america when the
little kids did it yeah wow
the girls that were wholeheartedly came
by yesterday
from the bikini wow they look like a
radio shack
oh my god all the wires coming out radio
shack is the greatest
she been lord i thought i heard somebody
say it's a tandy corporation
ah that's too good that was
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] in here what
happened because it's [ __ ] hidden
like we're drinking a little fast i
think jordan lopez beer listen if you
want to get [ __ ] up
you don't have a lot of time
my beer i think this is i think the
contents i think it has
way more alcohol than it's supposed to
like if they you know
you know like when you weigh a truck
like hey man this truck is supposed to
be on the road this [ __ ] is a
thousand pounds overweight
uh this is i think if the alcohol
beverage corporation
tested this they'd be running around
with consulting with a ladder on the
back
yeah and they're they're not small and
but they do have girth as well all right
ktvb ktvb.com reported this one idaho
republican votes against using federal
funds for early education
says it makes it easier for mothers to
come out of the home
right just during women's history month
okay so what he did was representative
charles shepherd
uh he uh basically said i don't think
anybody does a better job than mothers
in the home
and any bill that makes it easier or
more convenient for mothers to come out
of the home
and let others raise their children i
don't think that's a good direction for
us to be going his name is charlie
shepherd he's a charlie shepherd man
[ __ ] you
your thoughts are reversed man what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] leave it to bieber eh right it
was a house bill 226 and it was supposed
to raise
state board of education no it did not
pass you know
stupid ass that's retro we like retro
[ __ ] that's good you know
wallabies and then and tie-dye puka
shells
not some [ __ ] wherever your mom has
to i didn't how about i didn't have a
mom
how about that one what am i gonna do
sit around wait for donald reed to
[ __ ] pick me up
doug donnelly first of all donna is
probably the greatest reference ever
[ __ ] owned the lingerie store in
san fernando i didn't know she would be
in there
it's a wonderful life she was beautiful
but when you start walking down the
aisle
i would take that underwear i'll be like
that oh my god and my grandmother
she hit me so hard i could smell donald
responded like that
i have a shoplift controller on the way
home george is quiet back there they're
taking hits
[Laughter]
oh my god okay well the six million uh
dollar
uh investment federal grant did not go
through
and he definitely didn't want it because
he thought it it gave women a chance to
be home
you think it would have passed yeah we
get to stay at home yeah
you're the next contestant and the press
is right
all right moving right along that
[ __ ] hitting me going okay
stripes.com reports
soldier and data for conspiring with
neo-nazi group
seeks dismissal because grand jury
wasn't racially diverse
how ironic is that [ __ ] he was
conspiring with a neo-nazi group
and he uh seeks a dismissal from his
grand jury
because the grand jury wasn't racially
diverse so this guy
22 year old ethan melzer he's a soldier
and died on federal charges
to say that the names of the people i
don't think i think he says it's in the
news
how about if it was you that i was
saying brian kellen uh
you know got his golf cart stolen again
or he left his bike like sports like a
stupid ass they got his third bike
stolen
tell me about it [ __ ] wonderful over
here
charles schwab whatever his name is in
peoria whatever idaho
leaves his bike on the porch like a like
a dude in the 1950s
yeah [ __ ] three have been stolen we
live in a time where
you know well i thought i could trust
everybody in oxnard
it's the nard bike yeah i leave this
little beachy community i was bragging
to george mom hey man i just ride my
bike
everywhere go to the cleaners in my bike
i go to the grocery store my back and
everything on my bike and i came back
one day
someone stole my [ __ ] bike
how do you like it now uh it turned out
to be my next-door neighbor
my next-door neighbor wow you saw them
right in the next day no no they turned
on your next door yeah my next-door
neighbor was doing all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] he uh i don't know how he lived in
the house
did you find out he didn't because the
neighbor on the other side said did you
know anything about your neighbor i said
no and he goes well
he got caught stealing all the christmas
gifts for number one then he got caught
stealing about
30 bikes number two and he was running a
drug and prostitution ring out of his
house
and you think that would be enough to
keep him in sight like i do from idaho
exactly
take my [ __ ] running a prostitution
ring at home
you're never going to see me because i'm
going to be inside
washing it down and getting it back up
and putting it down and cleaning it
again
that was delicious very strong beer you
just see a bunch of these in the
backyard littered
all right this one is from the hill.com
south carolina senate adds firing squad
as
alternative execution method have you
heard that they should
have uh cut your hands off if you steal
you think so for real like let's say
yeah let's say you always want to play
let's say but yeah you whatever your
crime is that's what part they cut off
like let's say you go down to uh uh uh
uh baldwin pianos and you go in there
with with
you and some other dude go in there with
some guns
and you steal a baby grand ballroom
piano i say that
you get your hands cut off but they
bring a piano there and you you don't
know you're going to get your hands cut
off oh and you're playing you know a
nice little sonata
my gift is my song and
this song's for you and then from the
piano comes
a blade it just cuts both hands off
and i bet you no one steals a piano
anymore
i i've got definitely all those out
there color my world
they cut your flute off they cut your
fingertips off you try to play the flute
then they book a big show for you like
at uh
you know uh uh santa barbara bowl and
with a flute and you go out there with
no fingertips
all the people like ah the [ __ ] you
know try to
do the so whatever crime you commit
that that's what part of your body you
get hurt all right
all right well yeah they come and they
hold you down and with their thumbs
gouge your [ __ ] eyes out and put ice
cream in like a cantaloupe you're my
grandma put ice cream in the kettle
oh my god in your eye hole she put some
[ __ ] vanilla
pecan and europe [ __ ] with you now you
got a brain freeze because your eyes
were there and now you're trying to
blink and they just [ __ ] throw you
into traffic
you're a goddamn luau walking around
with a little pecan
right yeah yeah so so they can actually
choose it so if if they decide against a
legal objection
right hey send them an email yeah i said
i'll send them a note a horror back
here oh we're drinking another one all
right this ought to be come on hurry up
all right i got to read
um this next one uh i like this one as
well this is my
happy mag dot tv you'll understand in a
second no it's a man suffers nine days
you ever heard of happy mag
tv never ever well that's where i had to
go
deep in my research i'll tell you what i
did some serious
journalistic uh preparation for this but
anyways they threw this down it says man
suffers nine day erection following a
moped accident
so yeah nine days wait a minute i was
looking at it somebody somehow man
suffers nine-day erection following a
moped accident
said uh what are you running through
oh well
how did you hit my car huh
whip cheese over here
[Laughter]
whipped cheese huh the old whipped
cheese yeah remember the cows where you
put all the
crackers the the the [ __ ] gate 75
pounds that [ __ ] summer break
she's winning squeezing you leave sixth
grade you're a [ __ ] beautiful [ __ ]
individual running in you know
you come back [ __ ] lint in your belly
button
[ __ ] cream cheese dispensers little
squeeze cheese on your tacos i love that
[ __ ] okay
uh okay they said okay doctors made
mention to quite a particular uh
peculiar incident the incident involved
where you go how do they know
he's walking around town hey what's up
he fell off his moped and hit his taint
that's what it says right here the part
of your body between your genitals and
anus
uh developing bruising uh but no other
significant injuries right so one of the
[ __ ] everything i wrote a song
okay wait hang on everybody keep reading
i'm gonna leave my post for a second
which one's mine
that's beautiful hey can you hit your
taint is that what is that almost like
the reset button on behind
like a back of a tv you just push it and
everything gets goes back to normal
there's a better it is it's in between
between your butthole and the
yeah your balls take your butt right
tape the the clinical term is the
perineum
perineal oh the perineum thank you grant
that you know what that was going to be
my name in my band in high school with
the perineum
i tell him
[Music]
that you are with me here tonight
remember that song yeah of course
all right that's all i wanted to do the
big hit and says
thanks
that you are with me here tonight
your perineum my perineum in time
and time
rock me gently rock me slowly
take it easy don't you know
that i have never torn my paranoia
before
well done sir that's right for that one
ah
okay moving forward hell yeah when
you're an only child sitting in the
[ __ ] highlight of the day
stupid ass radio
and look outside the window like a
[ __ ] jackass saying
little kids coming running by riding
their bikes throwing [ __ ] buckets of
water at you because they know you're
sitting there looking out the window
[Laughter]
make you feel extra lonely oh my god
nobody's around with his dress
oh my god okay moving around a lot you
should be [ __ ] yelling into this
microphone wh
oh yellow biker very calm are they very
calm on that thing
i like this this is a this is very high
energy today wait a second i'm gonna
open my second one
the next one is from uh whdh.com
another big big hit uh it's uh obviously
on the other side of
this step i wrote these i [ __ ] a p.o
boxer
i have a friend w-h-d-h in austin texas
you show up it's a laundromat
[Laughter]
but this just didn't cheeto dust in
women's tea in a woman's teeth help
police
make burglary arrest cheeto dust
of course a woman was recently arrested
for trying to burglarize a home after
cheeto dust helped investigators link
her to the alleged crime police said
so officer is replying to a report of a
burglary at a home
uh in sheridan did they find her at the
nascar race
trying to sell trying to sell the stuff
that she stole
so after they pried uh okay they found a
stream
500 outside the old winston 500 the
smoker's dream
anybody wanted anybody want a duck
floaty
just take this orange powder off it
go ahead so what happened was uh okay so
uh screen that had been pried off with
a board in addition to a bag of cheetos
and a bottle of water that were left on
the floor near the broken window
a good so what happened police say
victim was able to identify car after
seeing her
cheeto residue was then reported and
found in her teeth
so they saw this lady afterwards they
said you do this she goes no and she had
cheetos in her teeth busted
and she went to jail wow yep
so there you go i don't know if i should
tell this story um
[Music]
she smiled at me she had cheetos in her
teeth i didn't hear anything that's all
i'm gonna do i
don't think it's being recorded
[Laughter]
listen i don't want to say anymore she's
a musical genius man
i don't want to see anymore what uh okay
here's
ironic and you uh you know i we all know
a lot about the serial killers uh
over the past few decades do you
remember the i5 strangler
at all go on state killer oh yeah so
okay so you know california's i5
strangler got it said
when they finally got him can you hang
on a second i guess i got a chicken on
the stove
that's how arrogant white serial killers
are
wow thank you very much that they
finally catch him
and he says this we're going to be gone
a while right okay okay let me tell you
let me take one wow
i got a chicken in the oven how about
that
can you give me a second yeah
is there hey wow man somebody's talking
pretty bad about ryan
so classic and brian would laugh at that
[ __ ] out of the show
you mean a great first show drinking
breakfast oh you gotta play it
we're drinking beers and uh let me find
it in the green room and
and georgia but 100 percent of time we
would go okay so okay
a convicted california serial killer was
accused of strangling and raping at
least seven women faced a similar fate
earlier this week
with an autopsy determining he was
fatally choked at state prison
okay that's how they do it so he yeah
prison justice what i'm telling you
is that prison justice is like they
never let that
right you know and it's so classic too
like russian will not stand
all right that's a big lebowski
reference to you that's growing uh
my wife rogers uh with his name kibby uh
was known as i5 strangler in the 70s and
80s
it was spotted unresponsive sunday in a
cell at mule creek state prison
southeast of
sacramento with a 40 year old cellmate
standing nearby
so he's just like looking up whistling
and they didn't and and no one
and there's been no there's been no
arrests or anything so they just let it
go oh yeah he's like
it means hillary clinton yeah that's our
news and let's get into voicemails right
now and uh if you want to leave a
voicemail
a big nose bastard i'm just working a
song for you like you should have your
own theme
song he's got a big nose he doesn't trim
pelosi no i don't that's a pretty good
one yeah
that's pretty good that was more of a
soulfire
that's why that's gonna be the chorus
we're going to voicemails and if
we got your head being the guest mama
rodriguez ladies and gentlemen
in case
holmes eating ice cream maybe the second
one the first one is that number one
oh good going hey mama you got your your
heads on do you want to put your eyes
on here dude the dude was a [ __ ]
choked on a mermaid
[Laughter]
daniel coda probably shouldn't say their
names
uh okay well uh if you guys want to be a
part of this and you want to ask george
a question or ask them some advice
or or ask if you want to ask a question
of the oh my god hi
podcast there you go the number is
818-533-184381 all
calls will be recorded and
shown at our discretion yes that's right
and then that don't mean nothing and
then we
and then and when they're worthy that's
what you guys come out there they're
trying to be
hey listen everybody that's out here i
don't know who's making the noise
but whoever's making it a lot of things
are going to happen in this jurisdiction
then he walks back in his [ __ ] house
he said nothing he had he said nothing
and that was it he's just trying to be
important i don't know who i don't know
who that individual excuse me who's that
individual right there
i'm your son oh that's right come on get
inside
[Laughter]
sweet all right well let's listen to the
first one i don't know how these are
coming so uh
uh producer grant's gonna throw him at
us
[Music]
and we ended on amicable terms
um emma kabal oh well done i love her
already
brian kellen i love her already moved to
church and
um i met with a friend
and she asked me if she could set
my ex-boyfriend up with her friend um
and i was kind of thrown off um yeah
you should be coming i broke up with my
ex and he's a great guy and i would love
for him to find happiness
but we just broke up maybe like two
months ago it just seems really soon and
i also
don't my friend is really
uh she's out there but she means well
okay listen you can stop it right there
no we can stop it i don't know that
girl's name thank you for your call
uh on the horror bath hotline
so that's a call don't get let's go to
the hormone
so in no situation and no way is it cool
to break up with a guy
and then have somebody you know try to
set that guy up with another friend
this is a big big world and there's
people everywhere and not only is that
it's hurtful it's something you'll never
forget
even if they were perfect for each other
the fact that it's somebody that you
were intimate with
is is no i'm there's absolutely
no and if somebody's out there that has
somebody that they're cool with hey god
bless you you know let's hear that story
because never
is it cool but you could see because
when you know
something doesn't go right here you got
a third friend they're like
well who's that and then you know they
try to do it on the down low
and it never it never works up out and
then
you know like it's not like this dude is
so uh much of a keeper that
he can't date outside of your inner
circle how about that one
man that's that's some psychological
stuff you know outstanding
what's your advice to her i i have never
[ __ ] go steal bikes
yeah exactly that's some of [ __ ] used
to live next door to me
no i i it's never worked i don't know of
anything where it's ever ever worked so
i don't i'm
accomplished the lives and it leaves
people hurt
and life is too short for however long
you live to be worried about that kind
of body right and she's forcing that
dude in your life
still she's making you be a part of that
guy uh his life
as well it's a horrible situation we
finally agree okay next one
there's one hey
hey brother i hope you're doing well man
and uh just not a question for you bro
if you have to pick
a late night snack will you pick a taco
or a flan
let me know brother hey join that camera
or two bro
hey watch ellie holmes i love that
latinos are just so
everything's going so well for us that
our questions can be what should i eat
tacos are flat
what a that dude the most classic voice
ever in the middle of the night
in the middle of the night momo flying
i say flan and you've got to be chilled
not room temperature yeah i'm a taco
it's too much acid in the taco you're
sleeping well
thought out that's true come on bro
don't you have reflux problems
i do a little bit probably because of
that but i i i love falam but i can't
imagine
have it in the middle of the night you
think it's because maybe you eat mexican
a few nights a week
a few this dude man
yes we do they got to stomp i'm sure
this year than i have in my life
we've uh we've around our tear i might
have you know
i don't think i've ever considered
myself a sexual being but this dude
they hey she is a scratch that i can't
completely
itch an itch i can't scratch
is this the beer talking hey but yeah i
think they got a chinese herb for that
one
it's called horror the horror
corporation no they're they're they're
married and they
have a listen here's another one how
about pulling out
if anybody's out there that has a
healthy sexual relationship
into their marriage more than 10 years
call
and say i'd like to know i think people
that listen i want to know
what is it about your relationship what
was it from the beginning
and what's still there that makes your
sex life
as good as it was from the day you met
from the day you married or maybe even
better
10 years down the road listen if you can
answer that question
for people who don't have it i think not
only would you make a lot of people
jealous which is a great thing to do
[Laughter]
but make people want to be you but also
i love to hear those stories because
sometimes you know people meet and they
you know a lot of times people try to
make things work that don't work like
when you're when you're dating and
there's a problem and you fight about
something and you don't like the way
they sit
or you don't like that they one is a no
more of an outside person and you think
you're going to make it work it's never
going to work
like there has to be some aside from
sexual attraction compatibility that
makes it easier to be
to be together somebody is in the sports
and they don't like to watch sports and
you know eventually when you're old lady
sitting next to you every sunday
watching
you know the game you're like oh yeah
but you know you can that can be
arranged as opposed to
somebody who gives you [ __ ] for wanting
to go to the dodger game or wanting to
go to a game
if you're visiting chicago like you and
i love sports yeah and whenever we go
someplace
we go to the football games or we go to
the nba games we go wherever baseball
games whatever
but imagine you know traveling with
somebody if you and i travel at united
you said oh i'm not into that i'd go
without you
yeah well 100 but i'd probably find
another comedian that uh you know was
into the things that i was into
i don't know i remember told you that i
wouldn't get it all right yeah that's
very good that's why we've been together
for 20 years
he had no [ __ ] right and our sex life is
great all right go ahead
yep we always pinch each other
nobody does it right you're gonna be
doing it
do it right there's some dead ass let's
see you do it
what dude dude my god oh my god hi
oh my god hi oh my god
all right all right that's outstanding
that's that's dude
that's like my regular we're just taking
five minutes
a lot of people could say let's get it
on but no not like a lot of people like
marvin gaye
no he was like whole octave it's crazy
wow he went he went deep he went deep
imagine i couldn't pull it off i
couldn't pull the that off
i have to do the way i did it there's no
way i could throw
no one can do your show either
shall we
wait let's just do it hi george he did
pretty good
that's a [ __ ] basically slasher
right there i asked you
want to ask me what you your thoughts
are on um
latinos beefing with each other
uh for example here in socal the big the
big uh
the big one is mexicans and southeast oh
i want to get your thoughts on that
well i mean brother i i don't know the
guy's name but thank you very much for
calling
and as a matter of fact the mexican
versus salvi thing
i'm not familiar on but luckily in
studio as a guest
mom rodriguez has incredible insights on
the mexican salvi
beef and it is definitely bad blood
between
the two different types of latinos i
think it's just mostly about the
cultural language how some words
offend other words in spanish versus the
salvadorian spanish
and also the territory that they have in
los angeles mostly
a lot of the mexican-american community
was you know
once the salvias come in they kind of
take over and you know they're great
people i mean i've dated a few salvi's
hey now and you know it wasn't a great
experience for me being mexican because
you always have that stigma like you
know there's a war between us
her parents are like my parents it's
always like that battle but we're
exactly the same people
maybe how about your parents brought her
parents that's never going to work out
in a relationship too
exactly yeah we brought him over here oh
oh okay
so so here's another one because that's
what makes this podcast unique
is if you're a salvia and a mexican in a
marriage or in a dating relationship
if it's gone wrong call this number or
if it's gone right call this number
818-533-1843 and let's see if we can but
i think what you're what you're saying
is right because there's there's
similarities in it and the language is
different and some words are insulting
but also if they come into an area
that's a closed area
and take over then you know maybe one
culture is a little bit more
um aggressive in how they
handle things or what more aggressive in
their work approach and it creates uh
when you're watching somebody you know
succeed and you're sitting in a chair
you're gonna be like [ __ ] those guys
yeah so i think that has a lot to do
with ambidia jealousy imbedia
yes that's crazy me and vivian
immediately
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's my take off on fame the word fame
the song
uh baby look at that and tell me
what you see you ain't seen the best of
me
yet oh man that's spain oh man i'm about
to throw some panties at you
all right we have another we have uh
what 46 more good good girl
she's crazy okay
hi hi
[Music]
yes yes yes let me think about it
yes listen man derek carr i love derek
carr yeah
and and when you play in oakland you're
playing
surrounded by legacy by love by
the historic field super bowl
championship teams
great teams great players you know when
he hurt his leg man
and it was a tragedy for somebody to be
that hurt
and it's very difficult to come back
from an injury
beca like that because it's almost like
if you were
in a horrible accident you were a driver
when you get on the road
you're gonna be a little bit skittish
and i'm not saying that
derek carr is but in football man it's
like
sometimes it's better to move along than
to get moved along
and russell wilson you know not that
one's better they moved him along
i mean listen russell wilson you know
still has years to play so does derek
carr
but seattle felt comfortable enough to
move him along which everybody gets
moved along
every great quarterback and i mean
that's what makes it even makes what tom
brady did
more impressive forget about people that
hate him or i'm not a patriots fan
whatever
just for the actual the act of somebody
that age
getting released and then you know a guy
coming out of retirement another guy
coming out retirement
and saying yo yo we're gonna win without
the guy that
has taken all the credit the guy who's
kind of the mastermind behind this
offense
and show that we can do it without him
yep and at the beginning of season they
they mentioned both those quarterbacks
as
possible mvp candidates at the beginning
of last season
yeah and now what do you think mama uh
you know i love a car man i just really
want to respect the process one more
year maybe
i mean how many years have happened
three years but i mean i mean
look what you're getting though no i
mean that's he does i agree with george
he has like this ptsd
man from from that hit every single play
you see him hesitate you see him just
slow down like he sees his
fall with every play yeah but he played
amazing last year he did
he did play amazing he did play amazing
wilson but
that's that's russell wisland yeah i
think i i don't know i i have to go
i'm voting with george i would say you
know it's it's not a it's not a
defamation of derek carr who's a who's a
great football player and a good dude
did we see him at the we saw him at the
game yeah yeah yeah yeah
great great guy and the fans love him
yes
and you know what if you would have told
me that
when the raiders left the field for the
last time the fans in oakland would have
thrown [ __ ] at him i would tell you yes
of course
you know yes of course and as much as i
love
mark davis a friend of mine you know
when they asked him before the week like
what are you taking away
from oakland to vegas any any memories
and he's like no i think we'll just
you know i love mark you know he's come
to the show and we go on we sit in the
box
great person but that that was not a
good answer man it's never
you know you get divorced you know i had
a hard time with my divorce but i would
say that you know anne
is with the best reason that we have
this girl that's just
this beautiful loving spirited
funny adult daughter and not not me i
i hurt them both and then you you get a
woman that you know will talk to you
again
when she probably shouldn't gave herself
part of herself to me
and then a daughter that you know i
didn't talk to her for a few years and
then now
everybody is happy and we do
you know listen baby there's there's a
humor that we have in our family that
was a little bit mean and a little bit
and way funny you guys seen it
yeah and maya's been great you met mine
when she was five she's four her fourth
birthday i meant mine
and so so i would say you know that yeah
absolutely
you you there's things that you take
with you when you leave and and that was
a
bad thing for mark davis to say because
it made
raider fans in oakland feel deducted
like it didn't matter where they played
right yeah and going to the black hole
was amazing
oh yeah i mean i mean george yeah i went
with him with he i went
the tunnel with him was almost cried bro
wow unbelievable mark david's done that
tunnel
oh oh forget it right what's the game of
the season monday night games out there
that was amazing anymore are we done
that's it
all right god bless america how do we
rap
well thank you momo rodriguez for
hanging out with us the whole time man
it was awesome
awesome hanging with you thank you brian
for being
uh and thank you for being so open
with your heart and your spirit and
how's your face how your heart
and uh thank you everybody that has
subscribed for
oh my god wherever you see it spotify
apple
tv uh zenith the power goes in before
the name goes on
uh wherever you find the podcast that's
40 years old magnavox
awesome that was remember this was yeah
oh yeah oh my god that's that's 1976.
god bless you thank you george evel
knievel wherever you are god rest your
soul
tune in oh my god hi next week
wow this [ __ ] is
you